Scientists can grow human kidney
tissue in a dish, which are
called kidney organoids.
These organoids typically lack
a pervasive and mature
vascular system, which is needed
for organ-level function.
Now, researchers developed an
in vitro method for enhancing
the vascularization of whole
kidney organoids.
They enhance kidney organoid
vascularization and maturation
by culturing them under
continuous fluid flow in a 3D
printed millifluidic chip.
Vasculature produced in the
organoids is pervasive and
contains open lumens.
Vascularization of epithelial
structures enhances their
maturity.
Segmented vascularized nephron-
like structures form when
cultured under flow.
Vascularization of glomerular
structures mirror in vivo
development with capillaries
invading the glomerular cleft.
Vasculature between different
organoids in the chip can
interconnect via anastomosia
The well-vascularized kidney
organoids have the capacity to
fuse with each other, creating
larger tissue pieces.
These organoids can be used to
model kidney diseases and to
test toxicity.
[Credits]